I love nature more sparkles we have to
admit that we didn't like you at first
Audrey in the original descendants movie
you were a total mean girl it was
obvious that Ben didn't have feelings
for you but you blamed mal anyway and
you turned into a total villain in
descendants three but your story hit us
right in the fields and by the end of
the movie you had really grown as a
character we're so glad you turned good
Audrey storyline isn't the only
emotional part of descendents three stay
tuned for ten of the most heartbreaking
moments from the latest descendants
movie Audrey at the proposal it's easy
to think that Audrey just needed to get
over Ben and move on
but the way she reacted when King been
proposed to mal made us rethink the
whole situation Audrey really had
feelings for a Ben she loved him ever
since they were kids
she grew up as the granddaughter of a
queen and she was pretty sure that she
would be the queen of Oliver Adhan but
when she finally realized that it was
never going to happen she was
understandably hurt this me farewell do
we all agree that squeaky and squirmy
are the cutest kids ever
these two new vks were both excited and
terrified of going to auradon and unlike
the core for these young decays had a
great dad they loves me and Smee loves
them when they were saying goodbye to
their dad we just wanted to cry
thankfully they had Carlos to reassure
them that they would see their dad again
soon but there was just so much love in
that scene like father like daughter
we loved finding out that Hades was
mouths dad
we realized that Hades wasn't nearly as
bad of a parent as Maleficent he really
cares for mouth and these two have a lot
in common
mouths mom would never have given up her
source of magic to help auradon but when
Hades handed over the amber to mal on
his way back to the Isle we knew he was
a good guy we're so glad they ended up
having a father/daughter relationship by
the end the queen of mean descendants 3
proved just how amazing Sarah Jeffery is
as an actress we
I've felt that for Audrey turning into a
villain but the passion in betrayal she
felt when she turned into the Queen Amin
gave us chills we could really see how
hurt Audrey felt and she sang her song
with so much heart that we could totally
understand why she was acting like a
total villain we even felt a little bad
for her it's definitely one of the most
powerful moments in the movie or beast
Audrey decided a sleeping spell wasn't
enough for Ben she turned him into a
beast just like his father had been and
we felt so bad for Ben he was confused
and scared and when Jay and Carlos found
him he was hurt but he trusted Carlos to
help him get the splinter out of
gorillas was so sweet and gentle and the
Beast was willing to trust him
Carlos is definitely going to make a
great vet family first now knew that
shutting down the barrier would keep the
Nuvi case from ever seeing their parents
again I think that we have to close the
barrier forever
these BK's wanted nothing more than to
go to Oregon but they had also been told
that they could go back and visit their
families when Celia Ouma and the rest of
the gang found out that the barrier
would be closed for good they had to
make an impossible decision they told
now they would return to a rough life in
the Isle because that's where their
families were Sleeping Beauty part two
Audrey really believed that being the
queen Amin was her best chance but her
actions totally backfired she became the
victim of her own sleeping spell just
like her mom before her seeing her
succumb to the enchanted spell was
devastating she was just a hurt teen who
was seriously misguided we felt so sad
for her but most of all we felt bad for
Queen Leah who looked super worried and
devastated she must have realized that
she had pushed Audrey too hard a tough
decision
now was the biggest champion for all the
BK's on the Isle of the Lost
but when Hades nearly escaped she had to
make an impossible decision she had to
decide between a threat to auradon or
losing everything she had worked for and
she decided that closing the barrier was
the only option it was easy to see how
devastated she was by this decision
knew she was betraying the vks the worst
kind of lie
Mel really got herself into a mess when
she told Evy about the barrier being
closed she left out an important part
she didn't tell Evy that she was the one
who made the decision
Evy was telling mal how she believed
that mal would do the right thing um I
am so glad that you were going to be
queen you won't be a part of these
conversations you must hand over the
case and now didn't stop her we couldn't
believe that mal wasn't telling me the
truth we knew this would backfire on her
eventually that's deep betrayal
there was no scene more heartbreaking
than when mouths lies hit the fan the
bouquets were so hurt especially Evie
her BFF had told a huge lie and she had
betrayed what the core for had worked so
hard for
uma was hurt too she had just begun to
see Mao is a good person and then all of
Mao's friends turned to stone
she was completely alone this scene got
us right in the fields which scene do
you think was the most heartbreaking let
us know in the comments thanks for
watching give us a big thumbs up and
don't forget to click subscribe for more
awesome videos we'll catch you next time
[Music]